this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
5 30 here on a friday morning we are
following some breaking news a fire at a
local warehouse and this one happened
just before 4 this morning we sent
hector mejia there he's joining us now
live on the scene this is near pecos and
stuart hector what's going on there now
well all lanes of pecos still close to
south of stuart but we just got another
update from fire crews they tell us they
believe the fire started in or near the
front of the building and you see those
burn marks at the front of the building
firefighters are able to now go inside
look for smoldering hot spots now that
the big flames are out and we also learn
a little bit about the business fire
crews tell us this is electric
liquidators a retail store the flames
someone spotted them around 3 44 this
morning a passerby in metro police first
reporting the fire thankfully no
injuries to report as many as 40
firefighters responded but now that the
large fire is out
most of them are being sent back to the
fire station but now the investigation
is just starting right now crews are
waiting for the fire investigators to
arrive and start looking into what
started this fire literally right now
the northbound lanes of pecos just
reopened heading toward stewart
southbound lanes are still closed with
pecos right at stewart
so that's the latest update from here
reporting live hector mejia let's in and
out over to nate for the latest on
traffic nate thank